what a wonderful role to you know really
sink your teeth into I'm so grateful for
it it was a lot of fun to play to work
with Vera Farmiga and and to work with
Freddie Highmore he was just a delight
there Corey is active as well aren't
they yes they are yeah and going back
and then watching the show myself I was
so impressed
really especially with Vera her
performance is at once giddy and manic
and strange and she just has so many
layers and it's such an interesting
performance and what about you Rowan as
well what inspired you to play in that
way well you know when I went into the
audition I was actually had two
auditions that day so I was trying to
find a look and it kind of went with
both of them and I kind of heard the
teacher did this sort of fifties ish
thing you know and when we when I got
the role and I went in and I said I
think we should do one of these kinds of
you know very period hair hairstyles and
then the the it sort of became
collaborative I think between myself and
Mike who was so wonderful in wardrobe
and Tom and hair and her look sort of
evolved over the course of it but we had
like a threat of an idea that I just
think it was a really iconic look I'm
really was really proud of how she came
out I think it would be wonderful for
her to become Norman's
sort of secret confidante it would be I
wanted to ask you what you think the
appeal is still of that mythology of
psycho and the appeal of both the movies
and as the TV series today because it's
still so strong isn't it well I think
you know psycho is sort of the original
horror film and it really stayed in the
public consciousness when you think
about Janet Leigh saying she didn't take
a shower after that that tells you what
kind of film that was and I don't know
just the notion psychologically of
exploring what could make Norman Bates
become what he became I think it's just
a brilliant premise I think it was a
really just it's a brilliant premise so
I can't say more than that what else do
you got coming up what do I have
I've just finished words and pictures
with Clive Owen and Juliette Binoche
and I have a movie coming out for
Nickelodeon that I'm about to shoot when
I get back called jinxed can you tell us
a little bit about each of those words
in pictures it's gonna be a wonderful
film they're both so good in it it's
like a you know I keep saying it's sort
of like a Dead Poets Society kind of
thing
they're both teachers with troubled
teachers in a private school that sort
of have a very conflicting relationship
and the journey that they go on is
really interesting
you